over the past couple of years author and
journalist dolly Alderton has seen her
star steadily rise her incredibly
successful debut memoir is a must read
for millennial women seeking comfort and
solace about their dating mishaps
through Dolly's candidness about her own
yet miss Alderson found herself in hot
water when she applied this candidness
to other areas of her life writing for
The Sunday Times Alderton confess to
feeling guilty over the privilege from
her private school education and the
affluent networks it afforded her
there's no question Alderton is an
incredibly talented writer but even she
admits without her private education
perhaps that talent might never have
been nurtured or realized yet this
honesty left many uncomfortable with
liberal luvvies accusing her of not
doing enough and others calling out this
privilege I think miss Alderton should
be applauded rather than berated there
is indeed a hierarchy of inclusion in
society but a key step to leveling the
playing field requires honest
acknowledgement by those with privilege
when it comes to an equality the
blissful ignorance of the house is why
things remain the same so dolly you get
a like and the thumbs up from me okay
right I'm gonna tell you a story now
story time a big field school egg test
you do you I'm all for choice Finn
yeah and they found out that my IQ was
above 140 okay and I was disruptive at
school so what they did was the state
paid for me to go to a public school
king of Hill in Oxford all right so
what's his public school well I know I
go there when I got there when I got to
this private school I met the very
people about head-on all right yeah I
was nicknamed Kevin because I was poor
like to wear a school uniform that
wasn't tainted and I've got mercilessly
picked on and was completely excluded
from any activity whatsoever take the
engine out after about a year behind
belt about a year and half the
perpetrators of the main of the bullying
both got filled in the code by myself
I completely lost it they put me in a
sanatorium I ended up in children zones
okay now it's a bad feeling thinking
about me right then you know how am I
gonna get on in life because these
people are just gonna block me with
everything I ever do as a plus so I just
got a little bit full circle with that
my own son okay has come from a council
background has managed to get himself
for a uni and is now an officer in the
army okay so he's a left-hander now so
it does show that you can nowadays
bypass some of that stuff and actually
become part of this so-called
social elite gentry or whatever it is
want to be but it is extremely difficult
and I did feel at the time as if there
was I don't feel some subhuman sub feel
inferior to anybody they were looking
down on me totally you know the
conclusion I reached out is exactly what
we were saying here that it's extremely
difficult to forge ahead because all
these people got such a massive head
start on you that they've got all their
friends in Deloitte's they've got and we
need to now the Army has acknowledged
that the army now does recruit from all
over there's not so much of it as it is
there's quite a few deaths from social
backgrounds becoming officers now and I
think it's because the government have
opened up and you can actually get loans
and you can get yourself into the thing
and educated properly Greg you your
career is a is a sort of a test case of
what we should be doing in this country
in terms of actually nurturing people
from all backgrounds when I was running
the BBC I remember saying to the end of
privilege I was saying - no I once said
everybody in the executive ok how many
of you went to private school and it was
about half which did you wish no all
right I'll give a half I've been saying
I then said how many of your kids went
to private are going to private school
where 90% yeah and that's I think the
problem Alan Bennett I said it better
than anyone I've seen he says this the
words of Alan in this book about engines
of privilege the words of Alan Alan
Bennett reverberates still private
education is not fair
he famously declared in June 2014 doing
a sermon at King's College Chapel
Cambridge
those who provide it know it those who
pay for know it yeah those who have to
sacrifice in order to purchase it
knowing and those who receive it know it
yeah or they should yeah and if their
education ends without it dawning on
them then that education was wasted yeah
I mean there was no doubt in my mind
people by pivot yeah that's that time
and that's the time their time to buy
privilege now i politic Lee I have I all
my kids went to state schools I could
have easily afford to buy because I
wanted to go to state schools because I
didn't want them to only know those
people in life I didn't want about the
government's successive particular labor
guards could have done more than they
have done to take this way first of all
I get in the tax breaks the public
school gets the second they could end
they could end the relationship between
certain schools well you know you go to
that school you get into a yeah doesn't
matter if you get a couple of eight
levels or no what you doing so you could
begin to change it so Michelle you go I
was gonna say is I think we've got this
fascination about equality and you know
when I well what I mean is we have this
constant desire to pull people down and
then pull this up and make everything
equal and life's not always equal if I
have an equal start it's not about
putting my background I don't have I
don't have like you know privilege and
all the rest of it I'm very grateful for
my background I've had some terrible
shocking things happen to me but it's
made me the person that I am I've got a
character I've got balls I know how to
haggle how to hustle how to get myself
in there I've got confidence and I've
created success and that is only as a
product of my of my bring and I think we
just need to be very careful that we not
say it's not our point that's not my
point I want to I want to come here
because I I also feel having gone
through some horrific experiences
including recently as well yeah but also
worse than this including witnessing
torture in prison in Egypt I I I would
not change my life experience because
it's made me who I am however and this
is where I think perhaps you will maybe
soon one day hopefully have a change of
heart
with regards to this one thing no no
this one thing which is when we look how
our children and we say do I want my
child to have to have gone through this
or being tortured in jail just to have
my life experience of whit's and street
smarts
and that's where you start thinking okay
well you know and I think actually I'm
glad I'd never heard of this lady before
I'm glad she's admitting this it's a
first step I'm a bit yeah I'm a bit
curious as to why people are criticizing
her for admitting it because they're the
ones saying you're privileged
they're saying you're privileged but
they're criticizing her for admitting
her privilege which is a bit weird to be
fair to how would she really say she
feels a guilt this is what she said
in the article I know that a person's
education does not solely define their
fate I know that as well as having a
sectional II good fortune I have worked
exceptionally hard
I can't change my education and neither
can I resent it because of what it has
given me but it has left me with some
confronting questions that no debating
society could have prepared me for
questions like how has my education
impacted my life
do I have to repent for a privilege I
did not choose and is there any point in
justifying what we know is unjustifiable
and she knows without a question had she
not had that education
chances are she would not have known the
right people to get the initial break
into the media chances are in the news
room she would not have been taken
seriously in the same way Michelle you
have even said yourself when you open
your mouth people have certain
expectations about who you are you have
to challenge in that moment so every I
don't need to challenge if someone
thinks I'm stupid
based on what I sound like well then
more fool them no but my point is she
doesn't have to deal with that dude you
see and there's a certain level of lead
Gregg raised sorry one y one white man
looks the same as another one
I would say this kids right you said 90%
suddenly from it went from 50% of 19
I'm dealing with that right now so I've
got there's two-year-old and I'm
wondering what I do with his education
and I've got all of these questions
because I don't want into habit London
where the education system has been
completely turned around in the last 10
years and the cinema and the state
schools are extremely good why are you
worried about sending you know but
there's well there are other issues that
you have to deal with living in urban
areas in London that perhaps you don't
have to deal with if your child is in a
country manor somewhere for example in
East London and you know you start
thinking of when you read these stories
about kids getting sad start thinking
well okay if he's in a boarding school
for example he won't have to be walking
the streets where a gang attacks him and
but ultimately I think ultimately I
might end up hurting on the side of
mixing with others because I believe in
that kind of society is it the little
Rupert who gets teed up in Oxford get
stood up and usually travels a lot
further a little Johnny just completely
taught me the answer is improving the
opportunities that people in state
schools get rather than trying to make
people that's far too glib IRS's thing
to say honestly that you will improve
all state schools so they're like this
they're not buying just education yeah
they're buying